Prince Harry now he's got himself into a
bit of a bind here and I know I know why
this is what he said to Tom Bradley at
it
there's a fair amount of drugs marijuana
magic mushrooms cocaine I mean that's
gonna surprise people but important to
acknowledge
well maybe it is but what he didn't
factor into his confession particularly
about drug taking in America is he's not
an American citizen so in a state like
California a lot of Brits might go there
and think oh it's legal to be seen
smoking split it's not unless you're an
American citizen the federal law for the
whole country which would apply to
non-citizens is that it's illegal so
he's admitted breaking the law that
could trigger a review of his Visa
status absolutely and you know the
threats to the country so that shouldn't
affect him too much but it just shows
because there's so many instances I mean
one of the things that he's been going I
think about you mushrooms